perfect segue into my next question your
appetite
uh
you some would refer to you
as what's it called greedy there it is
some people would say
that
you're greedy uh you have put
so much on display when it comes to your
love for food
the concoctions that you feel go
together uh it's even landed you a deal
you know a deal in the food space you
had your own meal at mcdonald's um
before i get to the meal what what what
the [ __ ] is going on with your system
let's just get into the to the meat and
potatoes of it why
why the mixture of such
random and crazy foods it's random yeah
you put like then you put like cheetos
and oodles and you do a lot of a lot of
crazy stuff this is how i do it
nobody showed me this but i'm telling
you okay so don't tell anybody all right
this how i do it i feel like you know to
do these things
to to have the
understanding that you can do these
things at some point in time
uh life life
life was hard
when did you
when
when were you in the position where all
you had was oozing noodles and cheetos
you said i'm just gonna put them
together why do you like such random
[ __ ] what is it
so
when my grandma would babysit me
i got
nine aunties and uncles okay and hella
cousins
so there was always barely any groceries
in the house and you had to make it do
what it do in the kitchen okay so
like i love food
so
because i was eating the same thing
almost every day like when she would
babysit us for like the summer time
we had to like just figure it out figure
it out figure it out and it's
has it ever has it ever put you in a
position where you felt like okay i
don't want nobody to see this i should
keep this a secret no i'm proud of my
food concoctions so you've never you've
never felt like i need to hide this why
it's heart to heart this is me and you
talking honestly uh-huh okay
you gotta have crazy gas
eating some of this stuff right let's
just let's just
let's just keep it 100 for a second okay
there's no way that your system is that
strong that you can take on that yes
that's what i'm saying like let's just
keep it on so you're telling me you're
telling me that you've never been like
i'm just going to wait till i'm home by
myself to eat this i'm not going to do
this around comfortably
i'm just asking there's no way that you
can do that like i've seen you eat some
crazy [ __ ] i got stomachache still
it has to be
how did the mcdonald's offer come about
did they come to you mm-hmm
called you randomly and said oh my god
we have such a good idea
we've seen your love for our our product
and how you eat it we would love to
offer you
and it just
made sense well they called my agent um
shout out to mark cheatham love him
and
they were well aware that i would go
live um
and a lot of my concoctions went viral
yes
yes that's how i'm aware of it as well
you do understand like that's the dope
thing about your brand
when you talk about
this young demographic you talk about
your fan base especially the women that
follow you you know you've created
and curated your own
ecosystem you know based off of social
media based off of engagement based off
of your impromptu moments right so they
follow you they love you
but i feel like your business has
evolved because of your honesty
the transparency the authenticity that
people have been able to attach to you
so it's really dope that you got a food
deal coming out of you just being the
greedy ass
what that's what it is you're being a
greedy ass
you got rewarded for it it's dope as
hell i almost spit out my wine you don't
need to spit it out by the way no way
you're gonna waste that wine you're
greedy ass okay there's no there's no
way that you're gonna there's no way
there's no way that she's gonna waste
that wine uh you might be the funny you
stop will you stop covering your face
like somebody throwing a baseball at you
you see she went no cause my i'll just
be laughing crazy
you